in all likelihood there was no malicious
intent behind it at all but we have to
be careful in situations like this we're
talking about a group of people who are
already often singled out because
they're different because they come from
a different country because they have
different needs and so we need to take K
I think to make sure that we don't do
things that set them apart and we enable
them to be a part of our communities in
as much as as is possible my party
played Camry is all about trying to
create and build a wheels whereby
everybody can live side by side without
anybody being hassled for reasons that
are out where they are control so it's
not so much that this particular issue
in and of itself is a problem or that
there was malicious intent behind it but
that we must just take care to ensure
that people who do arrive here people
who are refugees and who is escaping
often really awful situations that that
that they a bad situation is not
compounded when they come and live in
our communities with us I mean do you
think for example one of the reasons why
people are asked to wear wristbands was
said that employers could tell that they
weren't eligible for jobs and there
could be a number of reasons why they
were asked to wear wristbands they were
asylum seekers in Middlesbrough I think
last week live in behind red doors they
were perhaps other reasons for those
being singled out but it just isn't
helpful look I grew up in the 1980s when
I was in school we were singled out for
having dinner tickets free school meals
and current wisdom is that you shouldn't
stigmatize children in that way that
they should be allowed to blend in that
they shouldn't be singled out why
because kids are picked on when they
singled out in that way in the same way
as asylum seekers could be picked on
could be held and attacked even because
they'll easily identified as asylum
seekers and that's the problem here I do
appreciate that but there is also as you
know a live argument at the moment
involved in Britain's renegotiation of
membership of the EU about the question
of migrants to this country and their
access to welfare I'm not sure with us
got anything to do with asylum seekers
asylum seekers are usually people who is
well-poised usually it's fearful for
them it wasn't the whole point in this
case that they're entitled to food and
therefore that amounts to welfare I'm
not saying it's a good idea but I'm just
saying that it's a more complicated
issue isn't than just saying these
people shouldn't be singled out they
have by definition been singled out by
their status but my argument to you is
that you've raised the issue of the EU
and the debate about whether people are
entitled to welfare benefits if they
move between member states in the EU and
I'm saying that's a completely different
argument to whether or not asylum
seekers should be wearing identifiable
response no it's about whether or not
people need to be distinguished within
community given the public concerns
about the level of migration and indeed
asylum seeking well because of those
levers of concern and because of what
can arise out of those levels of concern
people can be arrest there can be and
there has been an increase in racially
motivated crimes for example that's all
the more reason why people shouldn't be
singled out surely we want to create
communities and a society where by
people can live together and when people
are forced to leave their homeland and
live in another country then they should
have an easy right of it and they
shouldn't be put in a situation where
they can be singled out for harassment
and potential attack and you feel that
photo ID cards are a satisfactory
resolution to this is that's what I
understand the contractors are going to
issue
well if it's a case of being able to
show some sort of identification in
order to receive an entitlement for food
or something like that then that can be
done through the use of some sort of ID
card but some sort of permanent feature
that people are forced to display in
public to single them out as a
particular in as a particular vulnerable
group potentially then that's what I
object to and I think many other people
do as well okay some people might say
the problems in society of people who
want to stigmatize people or interfere
with their lives not necessary with the
wearing of wristbands well I think that
we all want to live don't we in a
society where people live happily
together and without conflict and
without people being put at risk of harm
and where you know and some of these
people who've been forced to wear these
wristbands have said that they've been
harassed and ridiculed and and they've
had problems as a result of it surely we
must take those concerns seriously and
act upon them anyway the company have
said no that they're going to withdraw
them so they obviously accept it as a
problem too yeah I'm good thank you